all right so the great debate throughout
the internet which I thought was just in
the comment section of my Prometheus
video but it's not is whether or not
prometheus is officially an alien
prequel or a movie that takes place in
the alien universe but is not a prequel
and if you're going to look for a quote
from Ridley Scott it's really not going
to help you at first he was like oh yeah
I'm making an alien prequel then he was
like well it's not an alien prequel it's
a spin-off and it's called Prometheus
then he was like well it takes place in
the same universe as alien it has some
alien DNA in it but it's not a prequel
it was like oh yeah I'm making two alien
prequels one of them's prometheus so no
help there this isn't a video saying
whether or not Prometheus is a good
movie I have my review for that in my
review you heard my take on whether or
not as a prequel the Prometheus is not
an alien prequel it's not and now I'm
going to tell you why I think that but
first let's define a prequel a prequel
is largely defined as a work that
portrays events which include the
structure conventions and/or characters
of a previously completed narrative that
occurred in earlier time and in the case
of Prometheus I just don't think it
qualifies now if you disagree I feel
like we're going to be like Jules and
Vincent and Pulp Fiction talking about
divine intervention no one's going to be
like oh now I see I agree with you now
right off the bat Prometheus has no
characters from the movie alien secondly
I am not convinced that the events of
Prometheus directly affect the events of
alien mainly because it's on a
completely different place the planet
and alien and aliens is lv-426 in
prometheus is some moon called lv two
two three completely different planets
so in my mind said I'm like anything
that takes place on this moon lv2 two
three has nothing to do with the events
of alien Prometheus shows the story of
the space jockey from alien no it
doesn't that's on lv-426 this is lv two
two three it shows the origin of the
Xenomorphs that might be possible and I
might be able to buy that but if the
origin of the Xenomorphs takes place on
lv 2 2 3 how did they get to 4:26 and
the space jockey we saw in aliens that
guy clearly had a xenomorph pop out of
his chest you can tell something
ruptured his chest from the inside out
but tom skerritt said that that guy had
been dead a long time he's fossilized
fossilized that takes thousands of years
I'm pretty sure Prometheus does not take
place thousands of years before aliens
so you got to think to yourself a
xenomorph already popped out of that
guy's chest thousands of years ago
so Prometheus is not the origin of the
Xenomorphs they already existed all
right the big proto's xenomorph at the
end of Prometheus or the xenomorph queen
or whatever she
is is really insignificant if a
xenomorph killed that space jockey
supposedly thousands of years ago I mean
this thing isn't the first see no more
and that's not even thinking about the
fact that it shows this thing get birth
Don LV two to three not lv-426 which is
where a lien takes place
you see nowt UDC then if you take the
Xenomorphs out of the equation people
are like alright well it shows the space
jockeys it shows what they are and it
does but I don't see how that makes it
an official prequel the only times like
one fossilized dead guy showing the
species or race of what one dead
fossilized guy was in the original movie
that they showed briefly sounds like
more of a spin-off to me definition of a
spin-off something derived from an
earlier work such as a television show
starring a character who had a popular
minor role in another show yeah the way
I see it just sounds like a spin-off to
me this is gonna get really nerdy in
about three two one
I take Star Trek The Next Generation
they had the Borg in it Star Trek
Voyager showed the nest of the board you
know where the Borg came from it doesn't
make Star Trek Voyager a sequel to Star
Trek The Next Generation does not make
next generation or prequel the Voyager
and that's what I'm going to call
prometheus Prometheus is a spin-off it's
its own story that is a crossover for
alien they're Prometheus it's own story
alien its own story with a little bit of
data that's overlapping and then the
argument is wolven Phantom Menace isn't
a prequel then as much as I would love
phantom Ennis to not be a prequel to the
original Star Wars it is because it has
a few characters from the original
trilogy obi-wan Kenobi was in all three
of the original movies and he's in all
of the prequels Yoda's in two of the
original movies and in all of the
prequels and most importantly Anakin
Skywalker you see him in the Phantom
Menace and you know you're like this is
going to show how he becomes bad this is
what this prequel trilogy is all about
now if it didn't show Anakin Skywalker
at all then I'd argue yeah Phantom
Menace might not be a prequel but then
you still have obi-wan Kenobi and Yoda I
would almost argue that calling
Prometheus a prequel to the alien movies
is like calling Star Wars The Old
Republic a prequel to the Star Wars
movies it takes place in the same
universe but it's not really a prequel
so if the Prometheus sequel stitches
everything from Prometheus and alien
together I'll be more inclined to
consider prometheus part of the alien
prequels
yeah the term can change depending on
what they do in the next movie but as it
stands now I consider it a spinoff and
that ladies and gentlemen is what I have
to say about that and this video hasn't
locked down the entire argument I get
that the
we'll still exist months after I post
this video however I'm interested to
hear what you think about it so
Prometheus prequel or not a prequel
whatever you think comment below let me
know discussions why people exist and as
always if you like what you seen here
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]